and the accountants for the Scottish
national party have resigned in the wake
of the police investigation into the
party's finances my correspondent Dan
Whitehead is outside the Glasgow home of
the former SMP leader Nicholas sturge
and afternoon to you Dan tell us more
yeah this is a statement which we've had
from the SMP in the last few minutes
confirming that the accountants for the
party who have been in place for around
a decade have reviewed their client base
and are no longer the accountants for
the SMP this is what we've had in a
statement from the party we can confirm
that Johnston Carmichael will not be
providing audit services to the SMP this
year the national Treasurer is
undertaking a tendering process for
alternative provision and we have
advised the Electoral Commission of that
position of course the party like all
parties have a a legal duty to file
their accounts by certain deadlines and
this is yet another very difficult day
for the SMP and what's been an
incredibly difficult week because the
party now has no accountants the new
first Minister Yusuf sold Sky News
yesterday that governance uh in the
party was not as it should be and said
that it had been in a difficult 24 hours
this of course comes after the former
chief executive of the SMP Peter Murrell
who is the husband of the former first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon was arrested
and questioned for nearly 12 hours then
released without charge pending further
investigation back on Wednesday and at
the center of that investigation was 48
Hours of intensive search and police
presence at the property behind me here
which concluded yesterday evening we saw
of course there's evidence tents the
barriers the tape the police in the
garden and 15 to 20 or so officers
coming and going throughout the day
plain clothed detectives and uniformed
officers outside the front of the
property for two days now we didn't see
exactly what if anything was taken from
the property but we understand that
evidence from there if it was gathered
as well as the SMP headquarters in
Edinburgh where police also attended on
Wednesday it is now there their job to
go through that evidence perhaps account
papers details to see whether or not
there are grounds for any charges or
whether or not the case will be dropped
but at a very difficult time for the
party at the moment and that update
coming from the SMP confirming their
accountants of some 10 years are no
longer in place and the party is now
having to start from scratch and find
new ones